time for a room reset here's your challenge pick five things in your room you can store it out
put them back straighten them up or find them a better home go and do it then come back and tell
me which five things you sorted out my computer my cups my pillow my chair and my bed sheet
recent report part 2 compared to before you started how does your room look now tell me
what changed my room looks much cleaner brushing teeth in the morning here's a story imagine you
go to your desk to grab your pencil case but it's gone you look around and see another kid
using your pens at their desk they took it without asking tell me how would you
feel and what would you do I feel very frustrated and I will go and tell my
teacher about it here's a lively busy scene at a birthday party a magician did
a big trick most kids cheered and clapped but two kids reacted differently
Sam looked scared, and Maya looked bored.
Pick one of them, and tell me, why might they feel that way when everyone else is happy?